right now ten thousand baby boomers  become eligible for social security  every single day democratic congressman  stephen horsford is among 200 members of  congress pushing to pass social security  2100 that's the first major change to  this system in 50 years on average  recipients get 1400 a month the plan  would increase those payments as  inflation bumps up the cost of living  it doesn't matter if you are a  republican or an independent or a  democrat if you have paid in to social  security  over your lifetime you deserve the  promise of that benefit  and to be able to retire with a sense of  stability  and security  according to horsford's office to pay  for this the payroll tax would be  changed to affect people making 400  thousand dollars a year or more now we  reached out to a republican party  spokesman and did not hear back